so I had another question how can eating
fat lower my cholesterol okay it's
confusing because afterall high fat
diets will increase your cholesterol
right not quite
here's what happens when you do a low
fat diet normally you will increase the
carbs people that are on low fat diets
are really on a high carb diet okay and
anytime you combine the carbs like sugar
with the fat you spike insulin so not a
good situation in fact a lot of the
studies in that fact most of the studies
out there that show the harmful effects
of high fat diets are done with high fat
diets fed to mice with lots of carbs and
that's why they come out supporting that
you need to do a low fat diet but the
thing you need to know is that your body
does make cholesterol it makes a lot of
it it makes 3,000 milligrams that's a
lot in fact that would be equivalent to
consuming 14 eggs or a pound of butter
every single day so your body makes the
same amount of cholesterol so when you
lower the dietary cholesterol your body
will then make more okay so if you eat
more it makes less because we need
cholesterol
you know if it's so bad why does her
body make it you need it for all the
cellular membranes you need it for the
brain you need for your hormones
especially testosterone you need it for
the stress hormones called cortisol you
need it for the eyes you need it for the
nervous system you needed to actually
repair certain things in the body so
it's it's definitely supportive of the
endocrine system and the type of fat
that we're recommending on a healthy
keto is definitely not trans fats
hydrogenated oils or soy oil or lard or
deep fried anything okay we're talking
about healthy fats like coconut oil
avocado nuts grass-fed meats grass-fed
dairy like cheese Wow caught fish
grass-fed butter cod liver oil so there
is no studies that show that consuming
these fats are in any way shape or form
harmful to your cholesterol or your
heart okay what what's really behind the
spike in cholesterol
is the high amounts of carbs the type of
eating plan that I'm recommending is a
low carb higher fat and that way we
won't trigger insulin and we can lower
the cholesterol but some people might
have a temporary spike in cholesterol
because of the fact that the fat is
being released they're losing fat from
the fat cells and some of that fat in
there is cholesterol and triglycerides
so it has to come out but that's a real
temporary thing it's not harmful and
then it comes back down to normal but
the majority of the population will
notice a decrease in cholesterol once
they go in a low carb diet do it for one
month then check your cholesterol and
prove it to yourself as well as your
doctor hey you know what I just want to
say something only 30% of the people
that watching this video actually make
it this far and you did so I really
appreciate you thank you so much